um I called like child services on this
one I call Child Services on my eggs
because he pissed me off if you want to
hang out with trash and come to find out
you smell like dookie that's your
problem
what's the worst you ever done to a man
oh my god I've done so much things
evil
um
thing
probably
um
I mean it depends on how evil we want to
take it I have like levels you know what
top three top three okay so three the
least would probably be
um I stole this man's wives bags like
all of them her chanels her ysls her
dior's everything like I stole
everything from her yeah do you think
I'll get in trouble for saying that do
you think he'll
um yeah I saw everything all that [__]
um Louie duffels everything all types of
10 to 20 k word for stuff or more more
way more like I would say
50 around 50. okay yeah
about around 50 uh yeah like diamonds
too so actually no more think about how
comfortable you have to be to just
willingly say that [__]
but sometimes especially like these more
attractive ladies attractive is
subjective not your type but you know
the grand scheme of things
she's so comfortable admitting to a
crime that hasn't been prosecuted that
can still technically be prosecuted and
just do it openly that's how much she
feels free from consequences
I see young dumb rappers doing that [__]
yeah some people can see that and be
like
I've seen that girl around my bed around
my back disappear boom I think well you
know she stole it from the man's wife
which means there was cheating involved
which means
he probably don't want his business out
there and they could afford those bags
he probably would rather have the bags
being lost than the scrutiny that comes
with his cheating being over if you if
you're a girl
if you're a girl and all of a sudden
fifty thousand dollars worth of bags and
jewelry disappeared you're going to ask
your man some questions where my bags at
where my jewelry there's going to be
some questions jewelry jury yeah these
are Jews alone bro you just have to
[__] what is that what black people
hip hop and Juice hey yeah you said
jewelry you know what jewelry is jewelry
say that [__] again jewelry yo I'll tell
you bro leave that you yo get the [__]
up get this number two would probably be
um I completely vandalized this man's
home like I broke doors
um Smash TV is destroyed clothes
um through like a brick into his car
windows because I'm like yeah like I
have a car so I know like okay these
windows are gonna be a little bit like
not like crazy expensive but a little
bit expensive and if I break all four
like okay you're gonna have a bill there
pops tires so like you know Ben's Tires
they're a little bit expensive so
another bill there like I was just
thinking to myself like how can I make
this person have to spend so much money
right now you know TV over his pockets
yeah like TVs cost like good ones like
two thousand dollars like for the big
ones I'm like okay two thousand dollars
for the TVs let's say the car probably
will come up to like four thousand
dollars doors aren't that expensive but
it's ads on like clothes oh designers
shoes okay you're gonna have to buy all
this stuff back like you know I'm gonna
say this this
I don't feel bad for these guys
because if she's this comfortable saying
this [__] on a podcast she's been saying
much weirder [__] on her socials her
lives everything else
so these guys [__] around with this
girl knowing what she is
and then they surprised when they get a
turn my brother you got on the ferris
wheel don't be surprised when that goes
round and round you go this
if you smell if you want to hang out
with trash and come to find out you
smell like dookie that's your problem
so every time guys want to yell about
these women or whatever it is never
forget there's dudes lining up to bang
them dudes with money access income okay
they can get with a lot of different
women and they choose this trash that's
something
that I I'm no longer going to look at
the garbage for being garbage
she advertised what she is and I like
she's hiding it so how can I be mad you
signed up for it this guy is six at six
with was uh was clashing on that girl oh
she was claiming that he was speaking
with her when she was underage and then
he had all the receipts like nah I ask
you for your age and you told it to me
and I'm like I'm not talking to you
unless you're that age so we're good and
she kept dming them dming them in a
couple of years later she come out
saying this man was talking about oh
yeah well he was in my DM when I was
yeah yeah young and I was not even true
all the DMS were there so
shout out to 66. what's up my guy I will
never shout out anyone whose nickname is
the devil but anyways no there's one
there's one six missing
you said six three times no six at six
that's two oh okay I just heard six six
no six at six uh listen there's too many
sixes anyways I don't care
I don't I don't [__] with that shout out
with you
okay like it depends on your perspective
if you think this is like the worst one
but to me it was really bad because I
was like I felt so bad about it
it felt so bad
this is a number
number one I felt so bad oh my God ah I
feel terrible look at me I am repenting
okay so now we're on a podcast for
millions of people to see okay so this
is the most evil thing I've done I feel
so bad the person that has the mask on
shouldn't have the mask on
is the other person that should have the
mask on I'm glad she don't got her mask
on um I called like child services on
this one I call Child Services on my
eggs because he pissed me off and then I
was like yeah I'm done with this person
whatever like you know cheater [__]
piece of [__] liesible dumb [__] he had
kids I called child services on his ass
and I like
fabricated everything and like censored
things and they like went to the door
and like there was a whole process like
I don't even know if the Children's Aid
worker still visits them but she
probably does because what I said like
the way I AI that [__] you know like
real AI [__] like
fake bruises
yeah
[__] your family all right you know what
yeah you you said that you don't feel
bad for the guys but I'm not feeling bad
for the guys but man the trash the level
of trash is astonishing hey it's
astonishing it really is but you got
kids and you choose to hang out with
this trash that's your problem
yeah we already know you got kids you
bring this into your life
that's on you okay you're on that like
let's not say the obvious kind of thing
like we already know she's dressed so
we're not gonna go back on that there's
no there's no point of going back on
that so everybody knows and it's out
there so we know like that's the obvious
so you want to talk about what's the not
so obvious and the thing that we're not
talking about listen this one's gonna be
bad people out there there's always
going to be big people out there who are
going to advertise the kind of dudes
like blueface who say they gonna cheat
on you he cheats on you it's like yeah
cheating isn't great we already know
this but this is not some hidden thing
this guy's up on Front Street saying he
cheats on everybody he won't cheat on
you he tells you he's gonna cheat on you
then he does it like
what is the pathology of somebody who
hears all that and still goes in like
maybe it's gonna be different I look at
you guys you're the fool I can't talk to
the the crazy women like this this is a
waste of time
right they wasted time no point I'm
looking at you guys the ones who are
lining up to bang this broad hmm they're
saying sympathy you guys send me this
story because I'm supposed to get angry
at her like yeah what she's doing to
those kids is unfair absolutely and all
the stuff that she does criminally it's
on those men to talk but they're not
even charging her so the men are getting
robbed the men are getting their [__]
vandalized they're out here cheating on
their Partners they're out here messing
with somebody who advertises that
they're messy they're gonna break their
[__] and then you want me to feel bad
it's like
you didn't take accountability or maybe
you have for the fact that you picked
this woman
and then you didn't take care of me by
making sure you press charges when she
did criminal X it's like who am I
supposed to feel bad for
well you're not gonna you're not gonna
feel bad for the walking red flag I mean
she even died of that hair red to tell
you something you know what they said
about animals when they're like
different colors like poisonous so she
advised you that she was a walking red
flag and then she said that's just a
walking red flag it's like if you walk
in the street and then you see a skunk
and a skunk scratch the ground and then
you still want to pet that [__] and his
skunks turn around and he still want to
spend that [__] and the cross can't go
hey you still want to pet that [__] and
then you get you get around you get
Juiced you get squirted out
skunk is gonna do skunk things pretty
crazy so you fake bruises you fake [__]
and then you just made like exaggeration
story and then on his kids yeah like so
hit like yeah then they came and they
were like oh like we're seeing stuff
that your kids are being abused you know
you could lose your kids
and I was just like that sucks
yeah should have been nicer to me [__]
yeah that Canadian came out at the end
yay yay yeah yeah you should have been
nicer there to be nicer there for real
Stills yo my guy you know you should be
yo shorty came with it my guy yeah she
came in and she said you know what you
should have been nicer to a girl you
know I mean that y'all gonna come in and
then you need to be nice to her it
Stills yeah my guy for real
yo I don't care what is stabbing in the
morning
that Toronto accent is disgusting what
are you talking no Toronto Toronto stay
taken else yo will you stay sane my guy
yo you're bugging for Real
uh all right yo my guy that stayed crazy
man anything else you want to say yo
this girl's talking crazy that's it for
today's video yo my guy my dubs in this
video man yo seriously this then there's
things are done my guy yo
scene